does it give you any
inclination or hope about how difficult
it is to engineer
common sense reasoning so how
complicated this is this whole process
so looking at the brain
is this a marvel of engineering or is it
pretty dumb stuff stuck on top of each
other over and over
can't can it be both right i don't know
if it can be
both because uh if it's an incredible
engineering job that means it's
v so evolution did a lot of work it uh
yeah but then but then it just copied
that right so
as i said earlier the figuring out how
to model something
like a space is really hard and
evolution had to go through a lot of
trick and things these these cells i was
talking about these grid cells and place
cells they're really complicated this is
not simple stuff
this neural tissue works on these really
unexpected
weird mechanisms um but
it did it it figured it out but but now
you can just make lots of copies of it
but then finding yeah so it's a very
interesting idea that's a lot of copies
of a basic mini brain
but the question is how difficult it is
to find that mini brain that you can
copy and paste
uh effectively okay today we
know enough to build this i'm sitting
here with
you know i know the steps we have to go
there's still some engineering problems
to solve
but we know enough and this is not like
oh this is an interesting idea
we have to go think about it for another
few decades no we actually understand in
pretty well details
so not all the details but most of them
so it's complicated but it is an
engineering problem
so in my company we are working on that
we are basically a road map
how we do this it's not going to take
decades it's better a few years
optimistically but i think that's
possible um
it's you know complex things if you
understand them you can build them so in
which domain do you think it's best
to build them are we talking about
robotics like uh entities that
operate in the physical world that are
able to interact with that world are we
talking about
entities that operate in the digital
world are we talking about something
more like
uh more specific like is done in the
machine learning community where you
look at natural language
or computer vision where do you think is
easiest to it's the first it's the first
two more than the third one i would say
um again again let's just use computers
as an analogy
um the pioneers of computing people like
john van noyman and
um turing they created this thing you
know we now call the universal turing
machine which is the computer right
did they know how it's going to be
applied where it was going to be used
you know could they
envision any of the future no they just
said this is like a really interesting
computational
idea about algorithms and how you can
implement them in in a machine and
we're doing something similar to that
today like we are
we are building this sort of universal
learning principle
that can be applied to many many
different things
but the the robotics piece of that okay
the interactive
okay all right let's be specific you can
think of this cortical column as
what we call a sensory motor learning
system it has the idea that there's a
sensor
and then it's moving that sensor can be
physical it could be like my finger
and it's moving in the world it could
like my eye and it's physically moving
it can also be virtual so it could be
um an example would be i could have a a
system that lives in the internet
that that actually samples information
on the internet and moves by following
links
that's that's a sensory motor system so
something that echoes the
the process of a finger moving along a
car but in a very very loose sense it's
it's like
again learning is inherently about
disturbing the structure in the world
and discover the structure of the world
you have to move through the world
even if it's a virtual world even if
it's a conceptual world
you have to move through it you don't it
doesn't exist in one
it has some structure to it so
here's here's a couple of predictions
that getting what you're talking about
in humans the same algorithm is does
robotics right it moves my arms my eyes
my body
right um and so
in my in the future to me robotics and
ai will merge
they're not going to be separate fields
because they're going to the the
the algorithms for really controlling
robots are going to be the same
algorithms we have in our brand the
brain at these sensory motor algorithms
i today we're not there but i think
that's going to happen
and and then so but not all ai systems
will have
robotics you can have systems that have
very different types of embodiments
some will have physical movements some
will have not have physical movements
it's a very generic learning system
again it's like
computers the turing machine is it's
like it doesn't say how it's supposed to
be implemented it doesn't tell how big
it is
doesn't tell you what you apply it to
but it's an interesting it's a
computational principle
cortical column equivalent is a
computational principle it's about
learning
it's about how you learn and it can be
applied to a gazillion things this is
why i think this is
i think this impact of ai is going to be
as large if not larger than computing
has been in the last century by far
because it's it's getting at a
fundamental thing it's not a vision
system or a learning system it's a
it's not a vision system or hearing
system it is a learning system it's a
fundamental principle how you learn the
structure in the world
how you can gain knowledge and be
intelligent and that's what the thousand
brain says what's going on and we have a
particular implementation in our head
but it doesn't have to be like that at
all
do you think there's going to be some
kind of impact
okay let me ask it another way what do
uh
increasingly intelligent ai systems do
with us humans
in the following way like how hard is
the
human in the loop problem how hard is it
to to
interact the finger on the coffee cup
equivalent of having a conversation with
a human being
so how hard is it to fit into our little
human world
uh i don't i think it's a lot of
engineering problems i don't think it's
a fundamental problem i could ask you
the same question how hard is the
computers to fit into a human world
right that i mean that's essentially
what i'm asking like how
um much are we uh elitist are we as
humans
like we tried to keep out uh systems i
don't know i i i'm not sure i think
i'm not sure that's the right question
let's let's look at computers as an
analogy
computers are million times faster than
us they do things we can't understand
most people have no idea what's going on
when they use computers
how do we integrate them in our society
um well they're
that we don't think of them as their own
entities they're not living things
um we don't afford them rights um
we uh we rely on them our survival
as a seven billion people or something
like that is
relying on computers now um don't you
think that's a fundamental problem
that we see them as something we can't
we don't give rights to
so computers so yeah computers so uh
robots computers intelligent systems it
feels like for them to operate
successfully
they would need to have a lot of the
elements
that we would start having to think
about like should this entity
have rights i i don't think so i i think
it's tempting to think that way first of
all i don't think anyone hardly anyone
thinks that for computers today no one
says oh this thing needs a right i
shouldn't be able to turn it off or
you know if i throw it in the trash can
you know and hit it with a sledgehammer
i might
perform a criminal act no no one thinks
that um
and now we think about intelligent
machines which is where you're going
and and all of a sudden like well now we
can't do that
i think the basic problem we have here
is that people think intelligent
machines will be like us
they're going to have the same emotions
as we do the same feelings as we do
what if i can build an intelligent
machine that absolutely could care less
about whether it was on or off or
destroyed or not it just doesn't care
it's just like a map it's just a
modeling system it has no desires to
live
nothing is it possible to create a
system
that can model the world deeply and
not care about whether it lives or dies
absolutely
no question about it to me that's not
100 obvious
it's obvious to me it's okay we can
debate it you want yeah
where does your where does your desire
to live come from
it's an old evolutionary design
i mean we could argue does it really
matter if we live or not objectively no
right we're all going to die eventually
but evolution makes us want to live
evolution makes us want to fight to live
evolutionists want to care and love one
another and to care for our children
and our relatives and our family and and
so on
and those are all good things um but
they come about not because we're smart
because we're animals they grew up you
know the hummingbird in my backyard
cares about its offspring
you know the every living thing in some
sense cares about you know
surviving but when we talk about
creating intelligent machines we're not
creating
life we're not creating evolving
creatures we're not creating
living things we're just creating a
machine that can learn
really sophisticated stuff and that
machine it may even be able to talk to
us
but it doesn't it's not going to have a
desire to live
unless somehow we put it into that
system well
there's learning right the the thing is
but you don't learn to like want to live
that's built into you it's wow people
like ernest becker argue
so okay uh there's the fact the
finiteness of life
the way we think about it is something
we learn
uh perhaps so okay yeah and some people
decide they don't want to live
and some people decide you know you can
but the desire to live is built in dna
right
but i think what i'm trying to get to is
uh in order to accomplish goals
it's useful to have the urgency of
mortality it's what the stoics talked
about
is meditating in your mortality yeah it
might be a very useful
thing to do to die and have the urgency
of death
and to realize it to uh conceive
yourself as an
entity that operates in this world that
eventually
will no longer be a part of this world
and actually conceive of yourself as a
conscious entity might be very useful
for you to be a system that makes sense
of the world
otherwise you might get lazy well okay
we're going to build these machines
right and so we're talking about
building
ais what but we're we're building the uh
uh the the the equivalent of the
cortical columns the uh the neocortex
the neocortex and the question is where
do they
arrived at because we're not hardcoding
everything in
where uh well well in terms of if you
build the neocortex equivalent
it will not have any of these desires or
emotional states now you can argue
that that neocortex won't be useful
unless i give it some agency unless i
give it some desire unless i give it
some motivation otherwise you'll be as
lazy and do nothing
right you could argue that um but on its
own
it's not going to do those things it's
just not this is not going to sit there
and say
i understand the world therefore i care
to live no it's not going to do that
it's just going to say i understand the
world why is that obvious to you why
why why don't do you think it's ok let
me ask it this way
do you think it's possible it will
at least uh assign to itself um
agency and perceive
itself in this world as being a
conscious entity
as a useful way to operate in the world
and and to make sense of the world
i think intelligent machine could be
conscious but that doesn't not
again imply any of these um these
desires and goals and
that you're worried about it we can i
have a
we can talk about what it means for
machines to be conscious but by the way
not worry about but get excited about
it's not necessarily that we should
worry about it so i think there's a
legitimate
problem or not problem a question asked
if you build this modeling system what's
it going to model
yes right what's it what's its desire
what is what's its goal what are we
applying it to
right so that's an interesting question
um
one thing if it depends on the
application
it's not something that inherent to the
modeling system it's something we apply
to the modeling system in a particular
way
so if i wanted to make a really smart
car it would have to know
about driving in cars and what's
important in driving in cars
it's not going to figure that out on its
own it's not gonna sit there and say you
know i've understood the world
and i've decided you know no no no we're
gonna have to tell it we're gonna have
to say like
so i imagine i make this car really
smart it learns about your driving
habits it learns about the world
and it's just you know is it one day
going to wake up and say
you know what i'm tired of driving and
doing what you want i think i
have better ideas about how to spend my
time well okay
no it's not going to do that well part
of me is playing a little bit of devil's
advocate but part of me
is also trying to think through this
because
i've studied cars quite a bit and i
studied pedestrians and cyclists quite a
bit
and there's part of me that thinks
that there needs to be um more
intelligence than we realize in order to
drive successfully
the that game theory of human
interaction
seems to require some deep understanding
of
um of human nature that
okay when a pedestrian crosses the
street there's some sense
they they look at a car usually and then
they look away
there's some sense in which they say i
believe that you're not going to murder
me
you don't have the guts to murder me
this is the little dance of pedestrian
car interaction
is saying i'm going to look away and i'm
going to put my
life in your hands because i think
you're human you're not gonna kill me
and then the car in order to
successfully operate in like
manhattan streets has to say no no no i
am going to kill you
like a little bit there's a little bit
of this weird inkling of
mutual murder yeah yeah and that's the
dance and somehow
successfully operate through do you
think you were born of that did you
learn that social interaction
uh i think it might have a lot of the
same elements that you're talking about
which is we're leveraging
things we were born with and applying
them in the context
that uh all right i would have said that
that kind of interaction
is learned because you know people in
different cultures have different
interactions like that if you cross the
street in different cities and different
around the world they have different
ways of interacting i would say it's
learned and i would say an intelligent
system can learn that too
but that does not lead and the
intelligent system can understand
humans it could understand that you know
just like i can study an animal and and
learn something about that animal
you know i could study apes and learn
something about their culture and so on
i'd have to be an ape to know that um i
may not be
completely but i can understand
something so intel's machine can model
that that's this part of the world is
this part of the interactions
the question we're trying to get at will
the intelligent machine
have its own personal agency that's
beyond you know what we assign to it or
its own personal you know goals or will
it evolve and create these things
my confidence comes from understanding
the mechanisms
i'm talking about creating this is not
hand wave stuff
it's down in the details we i'm going to
build it and i know what it's going to
look like and i know it's
going to behave i know what the kind of
things it could do and the kind of
things it can't do
just like when i build a computer i know
it's not going to on its own decide to
put another
register inside of it it can't do that
no way
no matter what your software does it
can't add a register to the computer
um so in this way when we build ai
systems
we have to make choices about the the
the under the how we embed them so i
talked about this in the book i said you
know
it's a brain intelligence system is not
just the neocortex equivalent
you have to have that but it has to have
some kind of
embodiment physical a virtual it has to
have some sort of goals it has to have
some sort of
uh ideas about dangers about things it
shouldn't do like
you know like we we build in safeguards
into systems
we have them in our bodies we have put
them into cars right
my car follows my directions until the
day it sees i'm about to hit something
and it
ignores my directions and puts the
brakes on so we can build those things
in
so that's a very interesting problem um
how to build those in
i think my my
my differing opinion about the risks of
ai for most people
is that people assume that somehow those
things will just appear automatically
it'll evolve and intelligence itself
begets that stuff or requires it but
it's not intelligence of the neural
cortex equipment doesn't require this
the new cartridge equipment just says
i'm a learning system tell me what you
want me to learn
and i'll tell you ask me questions i'll
tell you the answers
but in that again it's again like a map
it doesn't a map has no
intent about things but you can use it
um
to solve problems okay so the building
engineering the neural cortex in itself
is just creating
an intelligent prediction system
modeling system
sorry modeling system you can use it to
then make predictions and then
but you can also put it inside a thing
that's actually acting in this world
you have to put it inside something it's
again think of the map
analogy right map on its own doesn't do
anything right
it's just inert it's just it can learn
but it's just so we have to embed it
somehow
in something to do something
you